HIS BROTHER CAYINGEP IS ON THE
OTHER SIDE, PICK TO THE
FLORIDA PANTHERS.
ANOTHER DEAL.HE HAWKS
HE ONLY HAD ONE GOAL IN HIS LAST
CKAKKO HAS IT BACK.
NO SCORE IN THE GAME.
YELLING FROM THE BENCH EVERY
TIME PATRICK KANE'S ON THE ICE.
EVERY TIME
BROUGHT IN BY SETH JONES, AND
IT'S TIPPED AWAY.
BATTED COME OUT WITH IT TAL
GOALIES, HERE IS DE eBRINCAT, W
CAN REALLY
BLACKHAWKS WITH A 1 -0 LEAD.
NEMETH GOT IT DE
HAGEL ON NOW WITH JONATHAN THISD
SCORES!EADY TO THINK HE'S
GOING TO STOP THIS SHOT BY P
PANARIN.
THE GAME TIED 1 -1.
GOOD WORK ALONG THE BOARDS.
LA
BUT PANARIN
>> I MEAN, WHO
>> THAT'S DEFLECTED.
A GREAT SAVE
GETS THAT ONE AS WELL.
AND THEN THE RANGERS THE
DEFLECTION SAVE.
I THINK
BEAUTITI
MISSED CONNECTION WITH STROME,
SECOND UNIT ON.
POWER PLAY AND HERE IS THE PASS.
CONSTITUTIONALAL
TO KNOCK IT OUT OF MIDAIR AND
COULDN'T CONNECT ON THAT ONE.
AND CAPAVES.
BORGSTROM LOST IT.
>> AND HOME HAS BEEN GOOD FOR
THE RANGERS.
AND HIT FROM DE eBRINCAT.
UNDER SIX
HE SCORES!CK CIRCLE
AND PUT IT RIGHT BACK TO THE
OTHER SIDE. SAVED
BY JGEORGIEV AND HE'S GOT THE
PUCK AND A
>> Referee: REVIEW OF THE PUCK..